today's video is brought to you by
summoner's war i've been playing this
game for a while and i can tell for good
reason why summoner's war is one of the
most popular turn-based rpgs on mobile
with over 110 million downloads
it's one of the most successful games
that boasts a huge global community
and even some esports presence
summoner's war is an rpg that features
over a thousand monsters to collect and
battle with to keep things fresh
the game also has weekly in-game events
and different dungeons that you can
challenge with your buddies
summoner's war is celebrating its
seventh anniversary an anniversary event
like this begs for a celebration of epic
proportions
so summoner's war is giving everyone a
hundred scrolls regardless of server
make sure to also check out the special
coin events wherein players can get
coins by just logging
in spend those coins in the 7th
anniversary shop to get some amazing
exclusive rewards for further
information on the big celebration
head over to the official instagram of
summoner's war now you might also want
to look out for the wish dance event
that will last until the 7th of may
i'll leave a link to the instagram in
the description box below as well as a
link to help you download the game so
hurry up and start adventuring now
when the show itself starts with the
terrifying entrance of a mass murdering
colossal giant
you know you can expect a lot of epic
entrances in the upcoming episodes
unlike most anime attack on titan's
entrances aren't always pretty but
they're enough to make you hyped about
the characters and the fights that are
about to come so today let's take a look
at 10 of the best entrances in attack on
titan and why all of us
love them before heading to the video
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
because more content like this is coming
your way now without wait let's get to
the video
starting off our list we have the
entrance of rainer during the fall of
shiganshina
before he turned into the suicidal
letter sniffing bastard he is now
reiner used to be a titan with quite a
lot of titan armor and
plot armor that kick in the ass from
annie gave him quite a lot of character
development and this little boy was
willing to destroy a whole populated
city just to become a hero for his
nation
but forget all of that this is season
one that we're talking about back in the
day we used to call him the armored
titan a massive giant with the biggest
set of armor the world had ever seen
cannons can't stop him blades are
useless and when he charges at you like
a bull you turn and you run away the
entrance of the armored titan was what
added a sense of dread and intimidation
to the whole shiganshina arc is this one
of the final bosses humanity has to face
well at least that's what we thought
then
[Music]
next up we have levi's entrance in
season one if levi entered the scene as
a regular citizen in shiganshina you'd
probably laugh and ignore him this guy
must be the shortest man inside the
walls but levi didn't have just a normal
entrance he arrived with his blades
drawn and then killed three titans
without even breaking a sweat there are
a lot of ways to give a cool
introduction to the most overpowered
character in the series but isaiah would
chose one of the most
innovative methods by letting the man
remove the eyes of a titan he might look
like a [ __ ] but that plays exactly to
his advantage
he can move around more faster and his
excellent use of the vertical
maneuvering equipment makes him even
more dangerous
admit it this is the scene that made us
all fish short people
coming in at number eight is the
entrance of the female titan
normally a giant naked female running
towards you isn't something to be scared
of but when this so-called giant female
kicks a man to the sky and starts
playing yo-yo with a dead corpse that's
when you draw the line and start running
away
since our maori trio had incredibly
shitty lives inside the walls they tried
to compensate that by making cool
entrances
reiner and bertolt destroyed the whole
city and annie killed a whole squad
there were two things that made the
female titan more intimidating
one she was the world's largest
overpowered athlete and two
she had a brain she covered her nape she
used human tactics and then she scared
the [ __ ] out of the soldiers no wonder
it was love at first sight for armin
because when a mass murdering female
giant spares you it's natural to feel
some gratitude isn't it
next up at number seven is the infamous
entrance of kenny the ripper
attack on titan entrances aren't all
about titans at number nine we had
levi's entrance and now we have the
entrance of his favorite uncle
and unlike most of the other entrances
in this list the introductions here come
way before the entrance itself levi's
words about the mysterious kenny the
ripper were both scary and intimidating
most of our first reactions were wait
levi scared of something is this man
even human turns out he is human but
then we find out he's an acumen so that
once again kind of makes him inhuman
kenny is more like a cheerful version of
levi and no one realized how badly they
needed that yes every ackman should
arrive with a cool entrance i wouldn't
be surprised to find out it's a family
tradition
[Applause]
[Music]
we have levi's entrance in liberio let's
make it to ackermann's in a row because
levi had a way more cooler entrance in
the bureau two of the warrior candidates
had gotten the so-called acrophobia and
this scene managed to give another
innocent the same trauma
porco was quite the energetic and
hot-headed guy back during the first few
episodes of season four but little did
we know all of that foreshadowed his own
downfall when he gets too cocky and
tries to eat aaron humanity's strongest
soldier decides to make his
entrance the same cycles repeated aaron
almost gets eaten
levi saves him and everything ends up
with the titan getting some trauma about
the devils of parodies so annie
reiner zeke and porco that's four in a
row who's next remember kids meeting an
ackman isn't a friendly thing especially
if the ackerman comes packaged with
blades
[Applause]
coming in at number five is mikasa's
entrance when she saved christa
okay that's three ackman's in a row now
isn't it didn't i tell you ackerman's
come bundled with cool entrances
this is such an underrated mikasa moment
that has disappeared from many top 10
charts but let's not forget it was girl
power that saved the future queen of
parodies from becoming titan dinner this
scene is the culmination of many small
moments ymir's energy fades away the
titans overpower them krista is about to
turn into dead meat and then within all
that tragedy there's the glimmer of hope
as mikasa approaches
her arrival and words are what turned
the situation upside down and the survey
corps soon took control of the situation
as they begin to slay the remaining
titans and amid all that chaos mugasa
also gets to earn the first and last
kill once again proving that when an
ackerman's around it always means
there'll be more dead titan bodies than
humans
at number four we have the entrance of
mali and the jaw titan in season four
the nation of miami may be the peak
example of moral downfall but let's not
forget these guys got one of the best
military strategies of all time
trapping the most dangerous rebel in the
world at the top of the tower and then
planning to gobble him up by hiding in
the lower floor may not seem like a big
deal but the mali soldiers have a way of
doing it in a cool way
this is like the ultimate comeback of
marley erin yeager destroyed one entire
city
well they're gonna do the same porco may
not have gotten to eat his full snack
pig's plan may have half failed and
gabby may still be ignorant about the
whole among us scenario but there's a
lot more to expect in this battle
between paradise and mali
reiner also seems to have abandoned his
suicidal thoughts because his looks say
that he's got to do some attacking to
the attack titan what can i say
coolest team entrance everyone
next up at number three we have zeke's
entrance in season two being a giant
monkey is actually mean material but
zeke's beast titan has a way of scaring
the living hell out of you simply by the
way he walks in the very first episode
of season two we're introduced to this
large ape who likes to throw horses and
watch humans getting eaten in the most
creative ways possible this is the scene
that took the titan shifters morality
levels from zero to -100 because the way
the beast titan fed mike to the titans
isn't something you can watch while
having your dinner this
is way before we learned about zeke's
backstory so in our eyes
all we saw was the world's largest
inhuman serial killer but let's admit
that zeke made an entrance to rival both
annie and reiner because the last thing
the show needed was a talking monkey
that enjoyed killing people
who thought the blonde boy who mastered
talk no jutsu would exit liberio with
the highest kill count
is armin done with flowery speeches and
convincing words clearly not because we
later realize he still speaks to annie
but with the power of the colossal titan
armin wreaks much more havoc than
bertolt and then stares grimly at what
he's done
clearly army needed to do a lot of
rethinking about his morality after this
scene if you look at it from a certain
perspective
this is the perfect revenge from
parodies marley's colossal titan
destroyed an entire city
and started all this tragedy and
paradise's colossal titan nuked half of
liberio and brought back that same
tragedy seems like the perfect metaphor
to show revenge
isn't something always sweet now isn't
it
topping our list we have erin's entrance
in liberio what better way
to have a cool entrance than killing
hundreds of people with a transformation
and then wreaking havoc inside a city
okay that wasn't motivation don't do
that in real life okay luckily there
isn't anyone to arrest mr jaeger because
he then starts killing the people who
were supposed to arrest him aaron's new
look and attitude in season 4 clearly
foreshadowed that he wasn't up to
anything good but no one expected him to
go full berserk inside a town populated
with people his morals and ethics are
gone his innocence and naivety has
disappeared and is turned into the most
powerful weapon paradise ever had eren
yeager takes no hostages
it's only victims for him his entrance
was what kickstarted all the events of
the ark and is still one of the best
moments in season four isa armor crafted
the greatest plot twist of all time with
this introduction of erin yeager and
well let's hope he won't disappoint us
with aaron's final plan
so there goes 10 of the best attack on
titan entrances so
the moral of this video is that in order
to have a core entrance you should
either have some titan power
or be an ackerman sound up below in the
comments below your favorite entrance
and if anything was missed
don't forget to mention that as well as
usual if you enjoyed the video
don't forget to leave a like subscribe
and hit the bell notification so you can
be updated as soon as we release a new
video don't forget to check out our
sponsors game
summoners war links in the description
by downloading you'll be really helping
this channel out and
you'll be playing a great game for free
stay safe anime fans
and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you